RACHEL: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BORDER
SECURITIES ARE BEING WARNED TO
STEP DOWN OR BE FIRED AFTER A
TUMULTUOUS FIRST YEAR ON THE
JOB.
PETE: IN A LETTER, CHRIS MAGNUS
IS NOT COMPLYING AND SAID I HAVE
NO PLANS TO RESIGN AS CVP
COMMISSIONER AND HE MOVED MY
FAMILY THERE BECAUSE I CARE
ABOUT THIS AGENCY, ITS MISSION
AND GOALS OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
WILL: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
RETIRED ACTING ICE CORRECTOR
JOINING US NOW.
TOM, WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS ALL MORNING LONG.
KIM POINTED IT OUT AND WHY DO
THEY WANT HIM TO GO IN MAKE
SENSE OF THIS.
>> YOU CAN'T MAKE SENSE OF IT
BECAUSE IF SECRETARY MAYORKAS
HAS BEEN TELLING THE TRUTH, THE
BORDER SECURITY AS OPERATION TO
CONTROL THE BORDER.
WHY IS HE PART OF MAGNUS IN HE
SHOULD BE GIVEN AN AWARD.
I NOTICED THIS MORNING IN FOX
NEWS.COM THERE'S A STORY AND
THERE'S A CLIP OF ME AND CLIFF
JENKINS TALK A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO WE WERE TALKING AFTER HE GOT
NOMINATED.
HE WAS A BAD CHOICE AND A NUMBER
OF REASONS, WHEN HE WAS IN
TUCSON CHIEF OF POLICE AND
ORDERED HIS OFFICERS NOT TO
SUPPORT ICE AND CHIEF OF POLICE
AND TALKED BAD ABOUT TRUMP
POLICIES TO SECURE THE BORDER
AND WHEN IT CAMES TO PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS IN TUCSON, HE
REFUSED TO WORK WITH MEN AND
WOMEN OF BORDER PATROL AND ICE.
HE NEEDS TO GO.
THEY NEED TO FIRE HIM.
BUT THEY NEED TO FIRE MAYORKAS
TOO BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING WHAT
MAYORKAS TOLD HIM TO DO.
RACHEL: YEAH, THE JOB OF
SECRETARY MAYORKAS IS TO PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY, NATIONAL SECURITY,
AND YET WE SEE 98 APPREHENDED
KNOWN TERRORISTS JUST THIS YEAR.
HE'S BEEN WRECKLESS WITH OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> I USED THE ANALOGY LAST NIGHT
YOU WANT TO FIRE A WAITRESS THAT
DELIVERED A BAD MEAL TO YOUR
TABLE BUT IT'S THE COOK.
>> ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF MAYORKAS
WITH BAD LEADERSHIP IN THE TOWER
AND MAGNUS IS GOING TO CONTROL
IT.
HE'LL PUT IT ON MAGNUS.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS NEEDS TO
WOMEN PEACHED AND MAGNUS IS
DOING WHAT HE WANTS AND HISTORIC
BORDER AND OUR COUNTRY'S
LEADERSHIP AND HE NEEDS TO GO
TOO.
PETE: THERE IT IS.
THAT'S THE BEST EXPLANATION I'VE
HEARD.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE HAULED
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS AND THEY
DON'T WANT HIM ANSWERING
QUESTIONS BECAUSE HE'S
COMPLETELY INCOMPETENT.
DO YOU EXPECT ACTION FROM, LET'S
SAY HOUSE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
NAH MAJORITY AND DO THAT I HAVE
THE GUTS TO IMPEACH MAYORKAS?
>> I'LL CALL THEM OUT TOO.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS AN
IMMIGRATION CRISIS AND JUST NOT
IMMIGRATION CRISIS BUT AS RACHEL
JUST SAID, NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
WE GOT OVER 1 MILLION RECORDED
GOT AWAYS AND THEY WERE ARRESTED
SINCE JOE BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT
114 PEOPLE THAT TRIED TO ENTER
ILLEGALLY AND 100 MILLION KNOWN
SUSPECTED TERRORISTS AND THEY'LL
DO US HARM AND IT'LL BE A BAD
DAY FOR THE COUNTRY AND
SECRETARY MAYORKAS MADE THIS
COUNTRY LESS SAFE SINCE DAY ONE.
RACHEL: THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT AND FIRING IN GUY WILL
NOT CHANGE THE POLICIES OR THE
SITUATION FOR THE PEOPLE LIVING
ALONG THAT BORDER.
TOM HOMAN, I CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU
TO HOLD THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS,
AT LEAST THE HOUSE NOW THAT WE
KNOW THEY HAVE THE MAJOR